when did film threat cross over into the
mainstream
well i would say that film threat
crossed over in the mainstream um
probably in the early 90s i remember i
got a check from the academy of motion
picture arts and sciences for a
subscription to film threat
a check which i never cached
um and it had uh
you know it had the logo of the oscar on
there and i i was just like i'm never
gonna cash this check i'm gonna keep it
and i i kind of felt that like people
were paying attention it wasn't just
that we were covering
you know underground filmmakers
uh we were also kind of giving a finger
to hollywood by the choices of the types
of filmmakers and the movies that we
chose to cover but then we would kind of
mock the pomposity of hollywood
some of the stories that come to mind we
wrote an article about comparing
hollywood's hierarchy to the caste
system
in india
with the untouchables at the bottom
which would be your pas and whatnot and
just explain how this hierarchy works
the power structure right
um so we were i mean these are things
that people actually do talk about now
but we were talking about early on
additionally i would be getting you know
other people for example steven
soderbergh wrote me a letter
in which he basically lambasted film
threat saying
you're awful you suck
you're terrible
um i can't believe it encloses a check
for all back users and a subscription
so he was obviously he was with
me um
but
i began to notice in the early 90s that
people were paying attention and there
were stories that got attention in the
in the magazine
um stories that
i mean now it's a thing that i guess
would trend on twitter uh but
you know
in when we did those stories
you know it was the first time people
were really hearing about them
you know um kind of challenging the
hollywood status quo and pointing out a
lot of the i don't think anyone
was doing that at that time and now i
think there's more of an awareness
of
the the pitfalls of being involved in
this industry
did you sell the magazine to larry flint
what happened
yeah when i when i saw the magazine to
to larry flint in
i uh you know
i i sold it with the caveat that like
i'm still involved right like so it
wasn't it was basically i didn't see it
as selling it to him so much as like i'm
basically giving myself a job because it
came with the responsibility of of
managing a budget
so
um
and and running the magazine i was part
of the package right so basically
larry was hiring me to do
film threat magazine via his company
and when i did it it's really
interesting um
we would sneak things into the magazine
that would be not noticed
this was difficult but if you looked at
like the side of some of the articles
there were things that we spelled
specifically on the side that if you
circled it like a crossword we were
doing we were sneaking messages into the
magazine
so it was still it was still like i was
still able to maintain my vision
right but an interesting part was when i
sold it to him the whole idea was i
wasn't giving him the magazine i was
licensing the name so that he could do a
mainstream version of it
and then i would retain the rights to a
thing called film threat video guide i
also received two pages
of advertising gratis in the magazine
and i would i would run advertising for
movies that we were distributing in film
threat video guide so i tried to do a
very creative deal
i mean i realized early on in my
negotiations with larry flint that
he wasn't going to pay me any money for
the magazine so how do i get value for
one i've given myself a job
right i've got a budget and i could
actually pay myself and at the time i
believe i was paying myself around
fifteen hundred dollars per issue
and they published six issues a year
so
right
um
you know we live in an age where a gig
economy and people doing side hustles
was
is kind of common it wasn't common but
for me i did that and i did other things
on the side to make money
so
i had this budget of about ten thousand
dollars for editorial per issue that
included photographer and other editors
and whatnot that i paid
including what i got paid
um
so i had that budget and then i had the
two two pages of free advertising and
with the two pages of free advertising i
just ran ads for movies we were selling
so that was another way for me to make
money so what i tried to do is be
creative with that deal and this is
something that i learned a lot i think
some of the best deals that i've ever
made
are ones i didn't take
because it's unbelievable
and i look i'm not i'm not a lawyer
but i have read all the contracts that
i've done for television and whatnot and
i what i really care about is what i'm
getting paid what my time commitment is
what are my obligations meaning are
there any holds on things like what are
my restrictions am i unable to work for
another network right what i try to do
is
what i try to do is knowing that
whatever they're going to pay me is
never going to be enough
i try to negotiate things that don't
cost money
actual out-of-pocket money for the
entity that i'm negotiating with in
order to get value for something that's
good for me for example holding the
rights to the name like i ran i still
owned the name i was licensing larry
flint the trademark to the name to do a
magazine if he ceased doing the magazine
i had what they call writer first
refusal which means i could
get the rights back from him so he would
have to offer to sell it to me first as
it is i ended up getting the rights back
because
uh
because the offers they were getting
were not what they
not up to what they were looking for
um
so i look for those non
things that don't cost money out of
pocket that a corporation can just go
that doesn't cost us any money
and because they're always thinking
about the bottom line in a way you can
kind of trick a larger entity into
giving you something that may have large
value
um for me it was getting free
advertising and film threat because i
know the size of the checks that we sent
filmmakers and because of that we
because i controlled the editorial so i
could write about movies that we were
selling and then run advertising for the
movies that we were selling
we sold a lot of vhs
underground tapes through film threat
video
because i remember seeing like i mean
the size of the checks that we were
sending to like york bootcaret were
substantial in the tens of thousands of
dollars
um
so
that was valuable
uh i think the most famous one the most
famous example and unfortunately there
may never be a deal like this in the
history of movies was george lucas when
he you know did star wars he was willing
to
you know take a lower fee to hold on to
the sequel rights and the merchandising
rights that will never happen to a
creative person ever again
look how valuable that became
and
you know so i think you really have to
be in any of the deal making be creative
even if it's something as simple as
you're making the movie and you have the
rights
to the t-shirt
that
a
character wait
wears in a pivotal scene in the movie
you know what i'm saying like i know
that sounds crazy
but like if there's a way that you can
find um that can be something to
something you can monetize from the film
that doesn't doesn't cost anything for
the entity that's funding it to give you
does that make sense am i being clear
yeah so so i did that and then i learned
from that experience with other deals
that i made going forward especially
with doing um work in television
and whatnot
and also when i did a film my big fat
independent movie those same things kind
of came into play
where i look for
a creative way to do a deal and i think
um we spoke earlier in our conversation
about being an artist and being creative
i think it's important to be creative
from a business standpoint
because that will that will serve you
well
when i sold
my big fat independent movie to anchor
bay
entertainment um they gave us
um so they were gonna
i made this movie called my big fat
independent movie which is a spoof
comedy right
i co-wrote it with two other comedy
writers um the director is a guy named
philip zlodorinski and the whole point
was to pepper it with some some cameos
people like bob odenkirk padgett
brewster in it
um uh clint howard and we were just
gonna make a cheesy comedy but um we
well we didn't get into sundance we did
play south by southwest and then we
played a bunch of
medium level festivals south by wasn't
the behemoth it is today
but we played some medium-sized
festivals and finally got an offer from
anchor bay entertainment
um they were going to release it on
video and dvd
and i was really gratified when we
started negotiating i showed them the
marketing materials that we had
and to me marketing materials are a way
to boost your the value of your film
to me and i explained this
in my book the ultimate film festival
survival guide i always say you got to
look at your movie like a stock
what can you do to increase the value of
that movie and or stock well cast
cast will help increase the value right
good marketing materials
um i think are important because you're
showing to a distributor how you might
sell the movie it's generally the
distributor's job how to market the film
but i don't know that they can be
counted upon today it's important to at
least present here's one way to sell the
film and i do love seeing the evolution
of marketing materials from a film like
from the postcard a young filmmaker will
hand you at a film festival
to like what it ends up being generally
are vastly different but at least you
have to have some example of how the
movie might be marketed and that at
least can spur the imagination of a
distributor as to like oh i see how you
can sell this now that's not exactly the
right poster but we can do a better one
um so i had this whole binder filled
with i and i created in our production
schedule for my big fat independent
movie
i scheduled time to do interviews with
the cast because they would be in
character in character makeup and
wardrobe you can't always count on that
so we did interviews for what would be
behind the scenes on the dvd
i did um we scheduled a photo shoot of
all the k all the actors that was like a
half day we're just doing the photo
shoot this is for the box cover
um and we did multiple variations of
that if you look up my big fat
independent movie poster we did parodies
of
iconic indie film posters like my big
fat greek wedding
clerks by kevin smith amelie among
others swingers was another one john
favreau's swingers so
we set up photo shoots with all the
actors to do parodies of those posters
and then did a series of those um we
also launched a website not every movie
had a website back in 2005.
which interestingly enough i got in a
whole conversation with the mpaa when we
launched our website that you could not
have post columbine a
character pointing a gun on a poster so
we had to change it instead of pointing
a gun we had to have the someone could
be holding a gun but it had to be in a
different way
so
it's very interesting actually the mpa
was very nice about it you know they
were just
requesting certain changes to our
website so as not to promote
stuff that was
uh
you know
you know highlighting gun use in a film
right almost like charlie's angels you
know how they right the silhouette was
of them pointing it up in the air the
other right okay i see yeah exactly so
we had to we had to make alterations
which was it was like
not a terrible compromise knowing that
going in but um the the actually the key
art image we used when we were on the
festival circuit was a guy pointing a
gun
um but in any case um so we had
developed all these marketing materials
in the course in the course of the
festival run so that when i presented
all these marketing materials to anchor
bay they were so impressed by the
materials they said they'd never had it
so organized we actually had a website
that had like corresponding with with
all the slides of like here's all the
key art and it was like i like you know
slide number five one two three four
okay we're going to use that one but in
this one we can we can sort of clip out
this person from
three eight one nine you know what i
mean like it was it made communication
really great and and they loved it and
it gave us an edge and also they were so
confident about the film that they gave
us an additional hundred thousand
dollars to release the movie
theatrically and the key cities that we
released by big fan my big fat
independent movie theatrically were all
because that's where the best buy buyers
lived
so the buyers who bought for best buy
which were cities like san francisco los
angeles
dallas detroit among others the movie
played and that's because that's where
best buy
the people who bought product for best
buy they lived in those cities so we did
a small theatrical release it was like
you know two weekends in and out
platform release put the film there and
we had end caps at best buy
we had two different versions a double
disc you know version with all the um
extras and i actually produced that dvd
i kind of tried to make it like a parody
of a special edition dvd with easter
eggs on every
on every page
one of the easter eggs um was it was
behind the behind the scenes
which was like a security cam shot of an
editor and you see it's like day one
he's sitting there it's kind of boring
crossfade
day two boring day three boring and then
he kind of smells
his armpit
and then it cross-fades again and he's
changed his shirt so
i know it's stupid
it's a very juvenile sense of humor but
um
but uh i i was having fun with all of
the extras that were on the dvd which
would be in line with
with a movie that um had jokes involving
subtitles
you know so
but i did learn that um
you know that really helps when you have
these assets what are these assets other
other assets that can help raise the
value of a film
obviously reviews can help
i'm not sure if they're as valuable
today
but reviews help endorsements even if
it's from a filmmaker who says something
nice or not filmmaker of some renowned
saying something nice i mean this leads
to things like david lynch presents or
whatnot
so
think of your indie film like a stock
and outside of the movie either yourself
or someone from your team
look at the ways you can increase the
value of it and be creative with the
deal
because whatever whatever they're
offering you i don't care what it is
it's never enough money so if they're
not offering you money that to me is
leverage
it's it's leverage and the thing that
that shocks me is how so few filmmakers
use that leverage if you're not giving
me money i have all the power
right and so what am i going to ask for
well i'm going to ask for i own this and
this and this and this and and whatnot
um
i can i can i can change the window
exclusivity window i can i can insist
that certain marketing money be spent to
promote the film
which i think is even more important and
i would even say like just having spent
time on the festival circuit i mean you
can
spend
you know tens of thousands of dollars on
a college education and film
or you could also
read books spend
tens of thousands of dollars on a movie
you make take it on the festival circuit
and that's almost like getting a masters
in film that experience
so
um you know i i i don't i don't know
that there and this is actually the
beauty of pursuing a career as a
filmmaker as an artist is there's not
one right pathway right there are many
there are multiple
pathways towards success but you have to
really be critical and if something's
not working
go in another direction i feel that
that's important is to really take a
look at yourself and go okay
not working whether it's my consistency
output of pages or
you know finishing on a deadline um
really take a look and create processes
that work for you i know that this is
going to sound very strange but
um
i keep a list and i do it every year i
have this very weird ritual
every new year's day
in addition to going to watch the rose
parade on colorado avenue
i do this sort of inventory of like what
i accomplished in the previous year
and i type out a list of the things i
want to accomplish in the coming year
i take this list and i print it out
on a piece of paper very tiny in really
inscrutably small type and i put it in
my wallet because i know i'm going to
look at it about once a day
right open my wallet about once a day
for something
and i'll see it
and i keep that list close at hand it's
something actually i learned olympic
athletes have done that
and i know that there's a lot of work
efficiency software most of that is
actually centered around communicating
with other people whether it's google
sheets which we use we pretty much use
the
google suite of products at film threat
um sheets docs
google slides etc for like marketing
decks
um but i always just make a list like
the dumb thing is is there's all this
software that tells you what to do i
just make a list and i do what's on the
list so here's the list of what i have
to do my sort of top list then i have
like you know this is what i need to get
done today this is what needs to get
done this week and when it's so
satisfying i take out my pen and i cross
off the list that's it's worked for me
um so i don't know i feel like i i'm
definitely a list junkie
i'm hoping to go back to
larry flint and and flint productions
sure were you working in his office or
the office that his building yes so they
so
larry flynn's offices were set up very
strange
um i mean you'd walk in
and everyone that walked in walked by
what we called the wall of shame
which was every magazine that larry
flint published which included things
like hustler
chic all sorts of adult magazines um
and then and then there were magazines
like rip magazine a heavy metal magazine
hot boat
pc laptop
um
you know magazines that were just sort
of traditional
you know simple magazine there was a
magazine called bbw
um big beautiful women it's about large
it's fashion magazine for large sized
um so he
he published a lot of different
magazines um they were kind of sectioned
off i mean initially um we were all
together there was like this corner was
all the adult magazines they never
referred to them as adult magazines
they called them men's sophisticates
interesting okay make of that which you
will okay so um
but uh
but in any case so they had that corner
and then there was the
sort of other down the hall that were
all the other types of magazines you
know your computer magazines um your
video game magazines uh the music
magazine rip um eventually larry flint
bought a building
which i believe is is is um still at the
corner of la cienega wilshire yeah um
with the big john wayne statue right in
front
i think it says flint publications to
the top in gold or something last time i
was there yeah yeah i mean eventually
well i mean when i live
when i first started working for larry
flynn everything was in one building
then they put they broke it up all the
men's sophisticates were in one building
and then they took all the non-adult
publications they put them in another
building so we had to actually move
across the street
and that building was very interesting
because there was a very prominent
attorney that was there who represented
people like
god magic johnson
uh kurt cobain and courtney love i saw
um in that building going up in the
elevator um
rodney king the the attorneys who
represented rodney king were also in
that building um that famous speech
where he said can we all just get along
that was right outside where i worked oh
wow at
film threat we were on the sixth floor
um of that building
and um
so we were separated for a while between
the adult magazines and the non-you know
the the more traditional magazines um
so uh
it was it was just
that was an interesting experience and
then eventually larry flint there were
rumors that he might have done this
because he knew his life was being
developed
into a movie i knew at the time the
screenwriters scott alexander and lara
karazewski i knew them because we did a
cover story on ed wood directed by tim
burton
and we wanted to get an interview with
johnny depp and the publicist was being
being a pain in the ass i'm not a look
they're a publicist that i get along
with
but
i think that publicists make a lot that
they they make a lot of power moves that
i find um infuriating at times and many
times i'll meet the filmmaker they're
like why didn't we talk to you it's like
i don't know i went through the
publicist that was the right way to do
it
but um having spoken to scott and larry
they interviewed johnny depp for film
threat for our cover story which um i'm
grateful to them for that
we then became friends and and um they
told me about their script for about
larry flint so i was kind of this
go-between between like scott alexander
and larry karazewski are developing this
script and at the time i think bill
murray was going to play larry flint oh
wow this is a very early draft of it and
then i had
to help them with the production i had
stolen out of the archives one copy of
every issue of hustler magazine ever
published from the beginning
and i gave it to them for the production
and they never returned it
oh scott and larry
dudes
return my collection how many issues was
that oh god i don't know
over a hundred i mean it was crazy
so um maybe they're still doing research
yeah i'm trying to think like when the
magazine was founded in the 70s
this was like the early 90s so 12 issues
a year
it's a lot it was a lot i mean it was
bins you know of these magazines so in
any case i gave it to them for the
production um and kind of end up being
something of a liaison between like
talking to them and then talking to jim
coles and larry flint like hey you need
to trust these guys they did this movie
with tim burton um
their their
at least their specialty which was they
were sort of developing was um
was you know biopics right i mean they
had written a bio pic of sid marty croft
that i eventually wrote about in a book
called the 50 greatest movies never made
um
they they i mean if you know anything
about sid marty croft you can go down a
rabbit hole of their lives i mean they
created the banana splits
um which they sold to hanna-barbera and
then they created their own production
company sid and then sid marty croft
created these are live action shows with
big either puppets and or
like giant suits and they
created shows like sigmund in the sea
monster
land of the lost
um i mean these are franchises that
exist to today i mean they kind of owned
saturday morning in the 70s so um scott
alexander and larry karazewski had
written a screenplay about
the it was a biopic of sid marty croft
they came from a family of polish
puppeteers
fascinating and additionally they even
opened a theme park in atlanta
based on sid marty croft productions one
of the famous rides of it was you were
in a pinball machine you were the
pinball
very so you can look all this up
you can go down a rabbit hole of the
internet or youtube or whatever to
discover this stuff but i ended up
becoming this liaison between the two
and then kind of connected them
basically just saying look we just did
this story on these guys they're legit
screenwriters who
did something really special with ed
wood i i think i think it might be tim
burton's best movie
um it's certainly the most traditional
of his films um
in any case uh so i i ended up just sort
of getting them to talk
so that something could actually get
made and that's when milos foreman
became involved and courtney love um who
played althea flint
and then eventually woody harrelson so i
was merely a i end up being and this is
i'm kind of like and no one's going to
know this zelig the character created by
woody allen which was this guy that
popped up i'm kind of a zealoug of indie
film i show up
in spots where i have a small
role in something happening
so if you see me pop up in things
and someone telling a story
about me
it's generally half true
what did larry flint teach you about
business maybe just in through
observation
wow um
what did larry flint teach me about
business
well one
we used to joke that lfp stood for low
pay
um because when we would look at folio
magazine and they would do like a salary
um a salary survey what they did was
they would release the annual this was
the most prized issue of folio magazine
was the salary survey issue and in that
issue you would see if you're an
associate editor at a magazine with this
much circulation you should be paid this
well we all soon realized that all of
our pay was at the bottom of the scale
right and a lot of my co-workers on
other magazines complained a lot
about it
oddly enough i didn't complain because i
felt so grateful to have the opportunity
remember i'm a college dropout i did not
finish college and here i am not only
did i write you know comedy and jokes
and humor for hustler magazine i went on
to do
you know film threat magazine where i'm
like this 25 year old kid
in charge of a magazine that's
nationally distributed i mean it was way
too young to have all the responsibility
that i had
but i did i did learn a lot from the
standpoint of just like trying to budget
so when you know
some of the editors were complaining
about the budget i'm like this is the
most money i've ever had and i can be
creative with this budget
so i i so he taught me how to budget one
of the things i began to do which the
other editors hated me for is i would
submit a budget every month because i
knew i had ten thousand dollars to spend
on an issue there were certain fixed
costs myself
another editor
my colleague david williams um other
assistant editors that we had like they
got a monthly fee um a freelance fee per
issue so i knew that that was fixed so
that took up like half the budget then
the rest of the budget went toward
writers and photography so i kind of i
would break it down but in order to keep
track because i was so afraid of going
over budget i would always like do a
budget report so i wouldn't just send
invoices i'd say here's a budget report
and it added up to you know 9 850 or
whatever it was
and he loved that so much he made all
the editors do that
and they hated me for that because then
they then they had to actually
keep a budget
um
but to me it was just like me being
financially responsible because i needed
to know like i can't go over budget and
i kept a budget because when i was doing
film threat independently i didn't want
to you know i only had x amount to spend
so so taught me about that additionally
um he brought me in his office once
because i was the weird thing was
um he began to refer to me as like this
wonderkid right because i could take
like a magazine
a lot of the magazines to me there were
just like really obvious graphic things
that some of the magazines weren't doing
or they had too many cover lines and i
used to do this weird thing where at
that time we were on like the third
floor and i would have like an intern
working for film threat go
here's a mock cover of the magazine can
you take the cover and put it on the
ground of the third floor and so all the
editors we would get all the writers
would gather around the window we would
look at the magazine and we could see
what can we read
we want or what stood out
so i learned things like on magazine
covers people make eye contact
they make eye contact
with people's faces on the magazine
cover
now you can do that and that you know
that will grab your eye because we make
eye contact with people make eye contact
with faces on magazine covers but i
thought well that's sort of uninspired
that's why all magazine covers
tended to look the same so we always try
to do something creative one issue a
film threat we did sort of this fake
cover of martin scorsese taking an oscar
and breaking it in half
and the cover line was will will martin
scorsese lose it meaning lose an oscar
um
that was the thing that i learned about
writing cover lines was they all had to
be kind of second read have some sort of
double entendre or something like you
read it one way then you can see it as a
different way and
um
but
because of that he brought me in his
office and he told me that he told me
this bizarre story about
factory workers that
they would change
the temperature of the light in the room
so it'd be lighter or darker and
people who worked in factories liked
that because it showed that management
paid attention to them i think his whole
point was that i'm paying attention to
you now you should pay attention to
people who work under you
right i mean we would have like these
idea jam sessions where we get together
and say what are we gonna
you know what are we gonna do what do
people want out of film threat right
um
and that's where stories like the
hollywood cast system story came about
among others where we were just like we
need to do a story that's a conceptual
piece there was always like we need
something that's a concept piece one was
you know i went and i was the
in a studio audience of a bunch of
different tv shows and then we collected
data and did a survey of like if you
want to see these tv shows here's how to
see them and here's what your experience
is going to be like
among others
i look back now some of them are pretty
dumb but would probably do well today
in the age of click bait that we live
but um
also the thing that i admired about
larry that he just taught me by example
was just like to be fearless
you know um
and we live in a time where it is
dangerous to be fearless
it truly is
so uh
you know
we
we need that kind of freedom to be able
to have conversations
and be able to
digest things that might be comfortable
and maybe to rely a little less on our
feelings i personally believe that
feelings are overrated
um and by that i mean i would have been
a terrible father if i cared about my
feelings
because i don't really feel like getting
up at three in the morning and changing
a baby's diaper but i did it
because that's my obligation and my duty
and i did a lot of things in order to
achieve certain goals that i didn't want
to do or feel like doing because we can
we can have all this discussion sort of
mining through trying to find out a
secret or a shortcut of how to do
something and here's what i've learned
of from everything all my experiences it
comes down to one thing and that's hard
work
and hard work
involves sometimes setting aside how you
feel about something
in order to achieve something i don't
feel like getting up at five in the
morning and writing a thousand words or
staring at a blank page i don't feel
like doing that i don't feel like going
to the gym i don't feel like
and i i
when i
talk to friends that they get so much
into talking about their feelings
i say to them and someone actually wrote
a book about this your feelings
right this is a book um
is it mark mark uh manson mark manson is
that the uh the subtle
the subtle art of not giving right okay
but i do believe that there are um not
that you can't indulge in your feelings
at an appropriate moment but when it
comes to if you really want to achieve
something
you have to set aside your feelings your
if your goal and you're on set and we're
losing light it's like it doesn't you
know sometimes it's like it can get
testy on a film set it just can
especially on an indie film set when you
have so few days to turn around a movie
and like you know um i mean i think it's
important to
obviously to be respectful to everyone
on set but when things are pushed to
shove we gotta go and a lot of time yes
it is like herding kittens and and
people gotta like set your feelings
aside let's get this thing
um and creating that environment where
that can happen but when i look at like
whenever i've actually accomplished
something worthwhile it's always because
i set aside
my feeling of not wanting to do that
thing
although i would say in the writing
process sometimes procrastination is
part of the process
if you look at my bookshelves and you
see how everything is alphabetized
everything is neat it's because i'm
stalling
because i'm thinking through what i'm
going to write and so i'm doing some
mundane tasks to build up to when i'm
going to sit down and do the thing
um but really really i i'll just say
that to me that
there's there's no secret there's only
hard work
and you saw that in him as well i saw
that in him yeah i mean this is a guy
that didn't give up larry flint did not
give a he didn't care what you
thought of him he didn't care like he
just didn't
he didn't care i think i think maybe if
he cared about one thing it's like why
um
mainstream media maybe didn't give him
the respect that he was owed because
they enjoyed the freedom
to speak their minds in mainstream media
because of what he had sacrificed sure
and so when i look at that
um
i think that whatever my mundane
complaints are kind of pointless
you know
and especially with everyone going
through such a difficult time
living in
you know
the after times the pandemic times the
you know all this all the stuff that
we've been going through
anything bad quote bad that has happened
to me this year you know a flat tire
this thing you know someone being you
know any
small thing if that's the worst thing
that happens to me today it is the
greatest day ever
because i'm alive and i have opportunity
and i'm just grateful so
i think that attitude can power you
through when things are difficult when
projects get difficult
so yeah perspective it helps
do you think you would have started film
threat had you been
today in 2021
yeah i don't think so i don't know like
i i mean i know i would have just done
something that was sort of contrary to
things i see i see sort of a sameness in
a lot of things that
become popular i'm very bad at
predicting what becomes the popular
thing in general i don't like mainstream
music in general you know
when a mainstream movie is good i
certainly will appreciate it but i tend
to go for whatever this sort of
alternative of the thing is whether it's
music comic books you know whatever it
is like that's the thing i'm most
attracted to so i'm terrible at
predicting and modern music to me to me
is just
it's garbage i don't really listen to
much
um that's happening but i've always
tended to when i look at my collection
it's pretty much all movie soundtracks
um you know because for the most part
there's no vocals and that can distract
you when you're trying to write but in
any case yeah so i i don't know that i
could have created film threat today i
don't know i mean maybe it would have
just been a youtube channel and not a
film review
website i i'm not sure
and
you know i i i don't i don't know our
you know like we do have a website where
you can read our reviews but are people
reading reviews now they read tweets of
reviews
do they read real reviews now
um i'm not sure so yeah i don't know if
i would have created film threat now
i will say this when i look at what film
threat began as
and i look at where we are in our
conversation about movies i believe it
was
way ahead of its time in terms of the
ideas that it espoused and i feel like
it's only now that it's come to fruition
meaning
we you know the the barriers to entry to
becoming a filmmaker are so minimal now
um in terms of being the possibility of
making films with an iphone
or whatnot you can make movie with a
phone you know um it's
affordable you know it's
the equipment is within your grasp to be
able to make a high quality
prop project
um what i do fear is we've missed we're
losing the artistry
and the sort of common usage of the term
content people just say content they
turn that
i i i'm not going to use that word
there's certain just words i'm not going
to use
i'm not saying the word content it's not
these are movies they're films there's
difference between a movie and a film
and cinema right
and content is sort of
i feel like content doesn't matter
content is to fill
you know
a release schedule for a streaming
service you know so
i i avoid that term at any cost so
um
i feel like if there's some level of
artistry that you can put in whatever
that content is
that's something to strive for but film
thread i don't know that i could have
created it today and i think that also
i'm a very different person
than who i was when i first started film
thread when i look back at certain
issues and i would never say that now or
like um i mean i i can 100
with 100 certainty i can tell you there
are things in the old film threat or
things i wrote like
jokes and hustler that will get me
canceled i think it's just a matter of
like who is getting cancelled this day
but i have such a vast
you know from podcast appearances to
youtube to having been on television for
15 years it's a gold mine of cancelable
material
but i think that's also why people kind
of like me is i speak my mind and i'm
not i
i like to say having
you know being from michigan
and being from detroit i have a highly
tuned detector
which
i can just tell you
that
so many people i meet in hollywood are
full of
and that's why i say that like you know
move here and pursue opportunities here
at your own risk a lot of talkers
a lot of talkers not a lot of doers um
so uh in fact it was weird because i one
weird thing when i first moved to la and
i would meet people
and they'd like give me their card this
is when people had cards they have their
address on it and i'd say hey i'll mail
you some copies of the magazine or i'll
send you a copy of this movie we just
released on vhs and i would do it they
were surprised because they're like no
one ever does what they say and i was
just like but i told you i would do it
and that's the sort of michigan detroit
guy in me of like
let's say i'm gonna do stuff
you know i do it
um
so
i it was just funny that people would
just be surprised wait you actually did
the thing
so and i would respond to every letter
um as we're going through i'm working
we're working on a documentary about
film threat
tentatively titled film threat sucks
and um we've been going through our
physical archives and oddly enough i
responded if someone wrote us a letter i
wrote them back
and i have every letter i have them in
categories i sort of have them in full
this is back when people would mail
letters to film threat
so um
really it's unbelievable like i look at
that archive and the kind of
conversations i was having with people
you know people who ended up some of
them ended up writing for film threat
and working for film threat and
some of them
told me to go my myself or you
know they were pissed off about
something that i did that's cool
whatever
why why were they mad at a revival
review or this and i think a lot of
times though they were trying to bait me
to get
in the magazine because we had a section
and this goes to being a contrarian
so there are two things that i noticed
that every magazine in the world did
they would write a
self-congratulatory editorial talking
about all the writers and how great this
issue of the magazine was about to read
it was utterly meaningless and it was
the editorial and i was determined to
always use that page to make a point
about something that mattered rather
than basically
doing a teaser trailer or commercial for
what you're about to read the second
thing was that they would
always do was a letter section that
would just say how great the magazine
was
and i was like we're never going to do
that we're only going to do we're going
to do a letter section that will only
talk about you know people who criticize
us you guys suck i mean we would have
the last word and not only that we would
actually physically cut out the letters
and reduce them in size and put them on
the page so you'd actually see i mean
we'd have to edit them for space
but we would put the actual physical
letter that was sent
um
from people and then we would reply to
all of them so we kind of encouraged
people we called it hate mail we kind of
encouraged people to
come at us whether it was our opinions
or whatnot a lot of people did photos it
was very much you know the kind of same
way that we participate with memes
um
looking through the film through
archives it's like oh my god this is
early like this is like early that
building that kind of community with
memes and you know trying to make each
other laugh and whatnot so
um
yeah it's weird revisiting that for this
documentary which
you may get to see someday hope so
hopefully we'll have a link to the
trailer but yeah sure this video there
is a sizzle reel that's out on youtube
that helped get attention for the
project but it's
been 10 years in the making to get this
documentary you know
made
that's a whole other thing i mean i'm
i'm not directing it i'm
um you know the quote executive producer
but i'm shepherding it because it's all
my
it's my personal story it's my personal
collection for my archives it's you know
a lot of other people's story there are
other people that are a huge part of
film threats early success and whatnot
so they're a part of that story
you